i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight we're
going to get to the latest desperate
move from the january 6 committee in
moments but first
the great unraveling that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now reportedly very frustrated about his
disastrous poll numbers president biden
joked about not leaving europe today
there's an old expression and a little
town in
delaware called clemontello a little
steel town and they say we're like poor
relatives we show up more invited and we
stay longer than we should so be careful
we may not go back
all right well i couldn't blame him
right hiding out in europe would seem a
lot more preferable to coming back home
and facing the wrath of america
now what you're witnessing is the great
unraveling of the democrats
85 percent of americans now believe that
the country is moving in the wrong
direction including a whopping 78
percent of democrats
so what's making people so pessimistic
well new gallup data points directly to
the economy not cultural issues not
january 6 concerns 67 percent of
americans say gas prices are causing
them financial pain 62 percent say the
price of gas means they're driving less
and 55 percent say gas prices are
forcing them to change their vacation
plans
and it gets even gnarlier because today
we found out that the biden economy get
this
contracted more in q1 the first quarter
than previous estimates so now it's a
1.6
annualized decline
not good
now it's horrible but the guy who
totally missed inflation a year ago the
angle was warning about it as you recall
says essentially don't worry be happy
the u.s economy is actually in pretty
strong shape you look at it
the strength of the economy households
are in very strong financial shape the
same thing is true of businesses
talk about out of touch like purposely
misleading the country and of course he
was reappointed by congress for another
term you just can't make this up zero
accountability ever in this
administration for getting things wrong
which they do a lot
and with all this bad news that's
swirling around hill democrats are
getting increasingly annoyed maybe
you've noticed this at the white house's
lame pr moves
democrat congressman ruben gallego of
arizona sniped to politico that i think
ultra maga is not a good talking point
and one democrat strategist said putin's
price hike is not meeting voters where
they are
but it doesn't matter because biden is
undeterred tweeting today that the ultra
mega agenda has always been about taking
away women's rights
in every single state
okay
it's actually so dumb
that it's sad at this point
and the only sensible conclusion has to
be that the biden people
they're kind of enjoying this it's
masochistic for them to stay on the same
policy course but it's also sadistic
because at some level
they have to be relishing america's pain
a rejoicing almost in the fact that our
workers are losing good paying jobs in
the oil and gas industry
if we just had a recent report that was
put out that's showing all of the energy
in the employment stats from last year
clean energy is winning fossil fuels
losing jobs
what a lovely woman
well just more evidence that the
democrats truly have forgotten the
working class in america
as arizona gop congressional candidate
renee lopez wrote newsweek terrific
piece saying american families are
struggling rather than address this
issue democratic politicians have asked
the working class to sacrifice more
while liberal celebrities dismiss the
concerns and even poke fun at those
feeling the impact
100 correct no relief at all for those
people who are hurting
but
democrats have a lot of time to cater to
the concerns of the radical left now
case in point
while they won't open up more federal
land for drilling
they are pushing for a transgender bill
of rights because americans they have to
be clamoring for gender affirming care
and gender identity to be included in
the 1964 civil rights act isn't that at
the top of your list
are democrats trying to lose as many
seats as possible in november
every major medical association agrees
gender affirming care is life saving
medically necessary
age appropriate and a critical tool for
health care providers
as a pediatrician when it comes to
making sure kids are healthy and happy
i know how important care that affirmed
someone's true identity can be
wow the goal here is insidious it's not
about equality
it's about destruction
destroying parents rights to raise their
children with the values that they see
fit
now rachel levine's values remember
they're better they're superior to any
parents who believe in traditional
gender roles
because of course she would be more
caring and more inclusive
after all it's affirming
not according to one of the young women
who at age 17 is now in the process of
de-transitioning after being bullied by
a so-called medical professional and
pushed into gender reassignment
meet chloe from california
my name is chloe cole and i am a 17 year
old detransitioner from the central
valley
i was medically transitioned from ages
13 to 16. my parents took me to a
therapist who affirmed my male identity
and the therapist did not care about
causality or encouraged me to learn to
be comfortable with my body
he brushed off my parents concerns about
the efficacy of hormones puberty
blockers and surgeries
my parents were given the threat of
suicide as a reason to move me forward
in my transition
okay this is beyond disturbing
how many young people do you think are
going through the same gender identity
indoctrination
my endocrinologist after two or three
appointments put me on puberty blockers
and injectable testosterone
at age 15 i asked to remove my breasts
my therapist continued to affirm my
transition i attended a top surgery
class that was filled with
around 12 girls that thought were they
were men most were my age were younger
none of us were going to be men we were
fleeing from the uncomfortable feeling
of becoming women
i was unknowingly physically cutting off
my true self from my body irreversibly
and painfully
okay
that the american medical association
and other medical groups and the biden
administration
actually support this it's not just
scandalous
this is criminal it is child abuse
these kids don't even understand what
they're doing
or understand that these procedures have
life-changing consequences every
american parent should watch chloe's
brave testimony
our trans identities were not questioned
i went through with surgery
despite having therapists and attending
the top surgery class i really didn't
understand all the ramifications
of any of the medical decisions i was
making
i wasn't capable of understanding and it
was downplayed consistently my parents
on the other hand were pressured to
continue my so-called gender journey
with a suicide threat
i will never be able to breastfeed a
child i have blood clots in my urine i
am unable to fully empty my bladder i do
not yet know if i am capable of carrying
a child to full term in fact even the
doctors who put me on puberty blockers
and testosterone do not know
this mutilation of our children
is what the democrat party now stands
for proudly
allowing along of course with wanting
more abortions obsessing about january 6
smearing everyone they disagree with as
racist forcing you to become poorer for
their green fantasy and funding hopeless
wars
that's what they think americans will
vote for in november
their great unraveling is underway
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else